I know future no Casey don't drink when
you're supposed to vlog what's up
everybody
today is a special day because we are
throwing a party yeah
but throwing a party for an occasion
that isn't necessarily a party throwing
occasion I'd only ever met anyone else
that's ever thrown a party for the
Oscars today's Oscar day I'm a big fan
of movies so TIFF and I love to throw
Oscar potluck parties and it's also good
to celebrate the Oscars just because you
know we do have a feature film script we
finished writing and you know we're in
the process of taking it to the next
step so it's good to get into the spirit
of moviemaking and for the potluck I've
decided to contribute some Cantonese
inspired dishes so in the canteens
culture there's a huge bun take a bow
culture and to my favorite vows are the
curried beef boughs and the toss abouts
the baked ones I'm gonna do my version
of it today in the form of sliders so
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so good hope it's good I kind of winged
the entire process wise laid up eyes
light up
yes that's what I'm looking for oh
really better than the other could I
actually been trying to this curry thing
for a while this is the best okay try
the pride of pork corn now oh I'm gonna
move it I'm good I wish we could share
with you guys every time we eat
something it's like would be like
teleport Talent Willy Wonka toss you
yeah
I didn't light up to this one the other
one overpowered it you should have had
me try this oh this one's not as strong
I ask you kuri kuri the really strong
flavor
oh good though there's not a like punch
in the face kind of good and the other
one this one spear as not as spiced
heavy I was so nervous as I was
finishing up cooking and stuff I was
putting into the container so I was like
hold on a second I kind of winged the
whole process because I've been having
experiment to encourage and different
things but I see you and stuff like that
I totally didn't go off of any of my
previous kind of sweating a little bit
the calm before the storm you ready I'm
ready
you're going to eat all the yummy food
everyone's bringing I know I'm ready to
get drunk
[Music]
why just walking around the house
looking hot and doing things
[Laughter]
[Music]
there is so much food David totally
tuned his foot here I was a bonus David
cuisine no he post made it in Iran to do
that so I could eat this instead of
having shaken up food in my backpack
I'm proud of you I'm proud of you all
right so I am three for three on my
Oscar ballot they look pretty good I
feel like I'm
bragging about the Nolan
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the most underrepresented minority in
acting you know what the funnest thing
is you're looking should I know
[Music]
hold up the Oscars just got less
important because
[Applause]
Jayla Brio like a real piece of paper
dolls
hijacking this family photo right
what's going on there's so many people
it's annoying
[Applause]
oh man kobe just won an Oscar Michael
Jordan dinner
[Applause]
[Music]
your face right there you go ready
[Music]
yeah one day there we go
[Music]
[Music]
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you feel about Jordan Peele
winning I'm very easy to see him on
MADtv and then his own show and then
from there it's like whoa to make some
unique pennies off stage like you see it
you know your net I never think the
person who's doing sketch comedy or feel
like like like as an artist yourself as
a writer comedian I think that gives me
kind of hope because I used to think
Oscars were like really a pretentious
like only or team towards each other but
then if you make something new if you
make something that the world knows wow
this is like
a chance for the little guy alright so
it's been a successful Oscar party
potluck I don't know I love throwing
these types of parties for the Oscars
because it's a constant reminder year at
the year of what I moved to LA for and
it's all subjective
you know filmmaking art entertainment
it's all it's all very subjective but
the fact that we can get ourselves to
care about something so much it just
means that we're very passionate about
it and passions are to convey you know
you do something for so long it turns
passion can easily go away it dissipates
so the Oscars is a it's a great way to
fuel our energy and it's a great way to
motivate we inspire carry that sort of
than magic
[Music]